bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs bonsoir
est loin d'un soir stéphane alors la loi
c'est très chaud parce qu'en fait on
donc on a fini bastia finalement un
grand moment assez éprouvant finalement
et maintenant déménagement de canal web
donc nouveau studio ce soir nouveau
studio donc très joli très jolie studio
très beaux locaux on est près des
champs-elysées sur la place de l'étoile
donc on est bien installé nouvelle
adresse aussi nouvelle adresse se voir
octroyer 17e pas mal quoi ouais on est
bien sur trois étages on se sent bien
dans ses nouveaux studios donc pour
faire d une émission relooké en fait
relooker et très bientôt on aura donc la
possibilité aussi d'avoir un studio avec
du public on pourra peut-être avoir des
gradins enfin lancée mais c'est pas pour
tout de suite mais ça risque d'être dans
un mois à peu près la possibilité donc
pourquoi pas avec de vous inviter si
vous êtes sur paris et la région
parisienne éventuellement d'assister à
l'émission en direct comme chez nagui
est tout à fait donc diagonale nulle
part ailleurs
alors l'actualité et loi c'est ce fameux
match
ladislav quatre chefs contre van der
wiel ce qu'on peut noter avant de parler
de ce match c'est le dynamisme du club
de cannes puisque c'est pas le premier
match de quatre chefs cette année cannes
qui s'avère à d'être une grande place
forte des échecs en france des faits
style des festivals avec un président de
club très dynamique
oui le président de club donc devenir le
vih que je connais très bien qui est
vraiment très jovial très familial très
très joyeux dans la vie de tous les
jours et également à présidents de clubs
hors norme puisqu'il organise donc non
seulement le festival des jeux depuis
une dizaine d'années déjà
donc très beau très beau tournoi
d'échecs et l'open ya des matchs de
temps en temps exhibition spectacle il a
une équipe en nationale une et en plus
il est mais il est parfait et il est
très bien que dire de plus voilà ils ont
donc un nouveau petit jeunes au club de
cannes échecs qui est donc vladislav
d'autres cas de chefs qui est donc
maintenant un peu comme il est chez lui
à cannes il un appartement là bas il
donc il a été plus ou moins naturalisé
cannois cela parlait français et le club
de cannes lui organise des matchs donc
notamment il avait joué contre alberto
david il ya à peu près un mois et demi
de sa part à métro david numéro un le
serbe aux joueurs pourquoi il y organise
ses matchs parce qu'ils veulent pousser
maladie cela va rentrer dans le top 20
mondial
actuellement il ya un an n'est pas loin
puisque je crois qu'il est dans les 40
premiers essais matchs vont lui
permettre s'il fait des bons résultats
ce qui semble être le cas il a déjà
écrasé alberto david et là il est très
bien partie contre van der wiel et s'il
confirme ce résultat il va progresser au
classement et donc se retrouver parmi
les 20 meilleurs joueurs du monde
oui c'est ça donc le principe du
classement elo est le suivant c'est
quand on bat un adversaire
quelle que soit sa force on gagne des
points tout simplement
donc le but des matchs c'est simplement
de jouer des parties en même temps
transformé sans spectacle pour faire
venir le public
donc ça fait un peu un double effet
c'est à dire que d'une part c'est
médiatisé que le jeu puisqu'un match
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel c'est
pas attendre à ces deux joueurs qui
s'affrontent ça fait deux blocs tout une
typologie qui se met en place
c'est donc très intéressant match
d'échecs à suivre en tout cas et donc
l'autre côté plus concret c'est que
vladislav tkachiev est en pleine forme
je
bien en ce moment et donc essayer de
gagner le plus de parties dont deux
points possibles pour aller de plus en
plus haut dans le classement mondial
alors pour pour connaître ces deux
joueurs
ce qu'on peut noter aussi c'est que
debrecen est diffusée sur un portail
sportif et sur ce portail sportif on a
accès à des interviews et des photos de
ladislav quatre chefs de van der wiel
contre qui joue il y avait aussi des
interviews des teams bacrot et de judit
polgar pour leur match contre bastia
peut-être on peut on peut annoncer 700
nouveaux sites qui diffusent notre
émission oui donc il s'agit de sport 24
points comme support 24 tous les dg
mentionné est effectivement vous
découvrirez la base des interviews
réalisées par jean-luc chavanon qui est
actuellement notre journaliste plus le
plus efficace le plus actif qui a fait
des très très bonne interview notamment
d' etienne bacrot de vladislav tkachiev
et donc depuis hier en ligne interview
de john van der wiel le boucher comme on
l'appelle dans le jargon les bouchers
hollande devrait donc sauf sur sport24
points comme je vous invite à amel
yahiaoui puisqu'il ya donc des
informations complémentaires sur os sur
ce match mais aussi des interviews
détiennent macro et rendez vous sur ce
portail en attendant et avant de
démarrer l'analyse de la deuxième partie
du match entre vladislav tkachiev donc
et john van der wiel je vous invite à
voir une interview que nous avions
réalisé
donc au mois de février si mes souvenirs
sont bons donc de vladislav quatre chefs
une interview que nous allons passer
maintenant pour remettre un petit peu
vladikavkaz chef devant vos yeux
c'était au tournoi d'enghien-les-bains
nom qui va parler un petit peu de ce
tournoi puis de façon un peu plus
générale on va parler un peu de
vladislav tkachiev aulas si on peut
envoyer cette interview
bonjour pour canal web stéphane laborde
ici en direct d'un gay nous recevons
maintenant un des tout meilleurs joueurs
du monde puisqu'il est numéro 34 mondial
l'an dernier aux championnats du monde
10 terminant 8e de finale il a donc ils
viennent du kazakhstan il est maintenant
inscrit sur liste française puisqu'il
vit en france c'est le grand maître
international vladislav tkachiev bonsoir
ovalis l'afld soit donc la liste tu
joues ce tournoi d'enghien donc il le
plus fort tourné en france organisé
depuis maintenant 10 ans est tué de
deuxième en plus fort joueur de ceux de
ce tournoi donc je pense que ce sera un
tournoi très intéressant parce que les
laits le liste des participants est et
comment mélange de jeu de deux joueurs
des de plusieurs sont de plusieurs types
par exemple il ya deux jours vraiment
expérience est tombé là ce qui commence
comme ça au off
il ya des joueurs qui qui comme les les
très jeunes espoirs du monde tchèques
c'est pour nommer refait et tient
beaucoup
donc ce serait très intéressant je pense
parce que c'est très en deçà ne peut
dire est un bon début de tournoi je
crois oui c'était c'était pas mal parce
que j'ai fait un nul dans les premiers
jeux gagnés dans la deuxième contre les
joueurs vraiment fort oui je pense que
je commençais pas mal mais on dire après
moi donc nulle en fait contre le plus
fort au jour du tournoi en fait valérie
salov je crois j'ai fait un nul contre
ça où je jouais je jouais déjà contribué
au quotidien il ya un beau championnat
du monde
j'ai réussi de gagner un match contre
huit mois quand même les télés très fort
c'est parce qu'il a été le troisième
mondial à l'époque donc je comprends qu
elle est vraiment pas donc pour vous
maintenant que vous avez fait un nul
contre le plus fort jours de tournoi
qu'elle peut être votre objectif final
est ce que vous voulez gagner ce tournoi
vous
vous vous positionnez comme vainqueurs
possibles de ce tournoi oui oui
évidemment c'est pourquoi je suis venu
ici pour gagner ce tournoi donc pour en
fait pour pour tenter à gagner ce
tournoi
alors vous allez aussi récemment fait un
exceptionnel tournoi à cannes puisque
vous avez gagné le tournoi de cannes il
me semble avec je crois un départage
finale en finale qui était remarquable
puisque vous avez battu votre adversaire
dans un blitz de départage où exactement
un général c'était un tournoi très
intéressant parce que si il y à deux
nuls donne dans les parties et dont on
doit il fallait jouer les partis en lice
et peut-être vous le connaissez jeu
j'aime beaucoup de jouets en glisse et
les jeux les plus intéressants à jouer
en finale contre monaghan amis m'ont à
mon ami depuis 10 ans montrent à
sketches de livres qui vigneault deux
co-stars aussi qui est mon entraîneur
qui est mon ami donc et j ai réussi de
gagner avec un blitz mais en fait j'ai
de la chance parce que c'était très dur
peut-être elle le plus le plus pas
désagréable mais cet adversaire pour moi
mais je veux dire que ce très difficile
ce titre et diffuse un très dur de jeu
contre quelqu'un qui était connais très
bien un jeu difficile veut toujours
contrôler amis comme on peut le voir au
tennis quand les joueurs qui se
connaissent un peu joué ensemble
oui parce que c'est vrai que pour pour
avoir pour être à l'esprit de gagner il
faut il faut il faut il faut de voir
l'esprit combattant combattants oui et
quand rami c'est difficile
alors ici un gain vous positionnez comme
vainqueur possible quelles sont d'après
vous les outsideurs ils ont les joueurs
pour vous qui se vont être les plus
dangereux dans ce tournoi donc surtout
les pattes de rosario sociaux après le
deuxième ronde
sept des vignes au couer qui ne l'est
pas c'est complètement couverts et les
favoris sont je pense donc ça de leur
salaire les gens tous les deux et je
pense que belafkih aussi
d'accord donc au tournoi entre ses dents
serrées beliatski qui est une star des
échecs mondiaux depuis très longtemps
puisqu'il ya 47 ans il a déjà été quart
de finaliste du championnat du monde
c'est peut-être l'adversaire le plus
difficile sa 9ème aleris à l'offre oui
c'est complètement vrai c'est ce que
vous avez dit mais elle est seul
problème qui n'a pas joué presque
l'année passée il n'a pas beaucoup de
lait practice maintenant donc c est
après après une telle ou telle zone très
pauvre
c'est très difficile de revenir aux
échecs c'est très difficile parce que
donc vous vous pourrez perdre l'essence
des échecs sont donc je pense que
peut-être ça de l'airé les autres ont
plus d'un giro comme comme les
vainqueurs possibles de 3 alors cet
après midi vous entamez donc la
troisième ronde contre je joue contre
bellestre et donc avec quelques couleurs
de pièces avec les blancs et donc quel
est votre pronostic pour ce match donc
je vais essayer je vais tenter mais
qu'elles sont quand même
qu'est-ce que passer encore donc en tout
cas un bon très bon début de tournoi un
point et demi donc ladislav quatre chefs
qui maintenant vie en france la france
vous accueilli depuis maintenant un ou
deux ans vous êtes premier sur la liste
française tout en étant de nationalité
encore du kazakhstan vous aimez la
france
oui j'aime la france je peux dire que
j'aime les france peut être à cause
d'une longue tradition que les russes
sont très proches mais très franchement
lié avec les français peut-être à cause
de cela mais j'aime le français sur
j'habite cannes depuis deux ans déjà
donc surtout j'aime j'aime beaucoup la
côte d'azur et paris alors sur internet
on a vu sur le site d'un gay notamment
vous aimez la france mais je crois que
les françaises aussi vous aime bien
puisqu'il paraît que vous plaisait
beaucoup aux jeunes filles d'enghien
quatre chefs merci c'était en direct
d'enghien une interview du numéro 34
mondial qui joue ce tournoi d'un gain
exceptionnel en france ses fans aborde
depuis un gain à vous les studios à vous
connecter
voilà alors à vous cognez vient c'est
plus d'actualité
et oui de suite au suite au déménagement
voilà peut-être on va démarrer donc
cette analyse deux parties donc c'est la
deuxième partie du match
actuellement ladislav quatre chefs mène
le match par 5 victoires et 2 à 2 qui
est un excellent score contre des
joueurs quand même reconnu comme étant
parmi les plus forts du monde
les voiliers disons que van der wiel et
de l'ancienne génération quand même il
faut rester relativement der wiel fait
partie des joueurs qui ont cartonné
grave dans les années 80 et 85 il jouait
vraiment très bien et gagné beaucoup de
tournois il a joué plusieurs
intervenants donc van der wiel faisait
partie des joueurs de l'élite mondiale
il y a une certaine dès maintenant
évidemment il reste très fort comme des
bases saines et solides quoi c'est un
bon joueur mais c'est plus forcément ce
que c'était donc on va voir dans cette
partie je vous rappelle que vous allez
pouvoir suivre cette partie avec nous
sur la vidéo avec les
on va marquer les cases et montrer par
des flèches aussi les actions des pièces
et vous pouvez aussi suivre cette partie
sur notre applet java en cliquant sur le
bouton jouer qui est à droite donc de la
vidéo et vous voyez un applet java avec
la possibilité de suivre la partie à
votre propre rythme voilà alors on va
peut-être démarrer maintenant
si on peut incrusté la partie sur la
vidéo par l'analyse de cette de cette
partie entre vladislav tkachiev contre
john van der wiel deuxième partie du
match
donc le match se déroule à théoule sur
mer donc près de cannes
voilà donc 27 4 chefs où ils ouvrent par
des 4 ou 4 en fait c'est un joueur très
positionnelle on te dire ça déjà sur sur
ce joueur contrairement à ce qu'on a ce
qu'on pense il calcule pas beaucoup il
fait plutôt de la conception assez
profonde et ça lui permet de jouer un
peu n'importe quel type d'opposition il
a une très bonne compréhension et
notamment au niveau du jeu de pièces il
est très très efficace donc si je peux
jouer des quatre comme 4 donc le début
c'est pas facile de se préparer pour van
der wiel déjà qu'à 26 c4 de six
cavaliers f3b 6 donc là on va l'on fait
ce qu'on appelle un ancien ghetto en
stephen pour les sit in avant le fou le
fou c'est 8 6 6 voilà que tu pointes
avait les cases va pouvoir se
positionner sur la case bessette et
ensuite exercer une action sur la grande
diagonale idées pour les noirs est temps
de contrôler
notamment la case e4 donc et donc
empêcher les blancs de jouer leurs
clients leur camp du roi oui et ici
alors on joue un coup le coup quatre à
trois qui dont le but est de lutter pour
le contrôle de ces deux cases la d 5 et
4 comme on l'a souvent dit dans la news
aux cerqueux lecavalier b1 va venir en
c3 pour contrôler ces deux cases la
pointe et on rouge et le but de ce coût
à 3 et de contrôler la case des quatre
pour éviter que le fouet fuite ne puisse
venir ici s'échanger contre
éventuellement le cavaly c3 donc
beaucoup de flèches dans cette position
mais l'idée positionnelle est simple on
se bat pour les deux cases des 5 et 4
ici à trois fouilles bessette et
maintenant on sort naturellement le
cavalier en ces trois des cinq donc là
un peu de la lutte pour le centre
stéphane donc et noir réagissent au
centre et c'est donc maintenant avec
leurs pions il contrôle bien faire
maintenant la case du 4 mai il avait le
désavantage de boucher leur fou
l'anglais 7 leurs fouilles bessette
exactement donc ici d'ailleurs vegf
ketchup pose immédiatement la question à
john van der wiel est ce que tu enterre
définitivement tofu ou est-ce que tu me
donnes le centre pourquoi et bien parce
que en prenant deux options en d5 les
noirs doivent reprendre maintenant sinon
pour éviter la perte d'un pion alors si
on prend du plomb là on arrive on n'a
rien on aura un pion noir en d5 bloqué
par l'option devant lui donc là le fou
sera définitivement fermée pourra plus
pourra plus passer et si on reprend
d'une pièce on se retrouve en
infériorité numérique au centre c'était
assez la partie cavaliers point des cinq
maintenant les blancs ont deux pions au
centre les pions des 4es eu deux contre
un seul pion qui est en eux six donc ici
en posant cette question
john van der wiel décide de jouer un peu
plus il cède le centre pour sauver
d'efficacité du fourbe et cette septième
coupe e3 et maintenant il va faire un
truc intéressant il va jouer g61 g62 en
général d'un sous genre de position
c'est pas un cours aux commandes et
puisque les noirs ont déjà joué le coup
et e7 e6 donc les cases noires peuvent
s'avérer faible
oui exactement donc imaginons un fou qui
viendraient angers 5 attaquants la dame
toutes ces cases qui sont autour des
pions en fait ne sont plus défendus par
les durs donc les cases noires sont
faibles mais l'avantagé majeur c'est
quand même qu'on va lutter pour le
contrôle du centre on va foncer ce qu'on
appelle un double option quito c'est à
dire qu'on va mettre ce deuxième foulard
le fouet fuite
angers 7 qui sera également sur la
grande diagonale et avec ses deux fous
croisés comme ça dès que le centre
commence à bouger et bien il ya toujours
un fou sur deux au moins qui sera très
efficace
on peut pas fermer les deux diagonales
ça c'est un peu l'idée de ce qu'on
appelle le développement qui est au rsa
le contrôle à distance en fait des
caisses centrales un peu dans un style
hyper moderne
l'hyper modernisme d'ailleurs qui date
d'hier au moins une centaine d'années
entre guillemets il faut des trois
cavaliers français 3d prend ces trois
fous g7 et laquelle va être l'enjeu de
la position maintenant je pense que le
gros débat dans cette position de l'adf
quel chef est un spécialiste
c'est la prise du centre est ce que les
blancs vont réussir à avancer leurs
pions au centre tir que tokyo 3 vraiment
envie d'avancer ici pour laisser passer
le fou angers 5 et faire un peu ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
commencé à taquiner les noirs sur ces
cases noires la cena notamment la
casaque 6 voilà envahir les cases noires
et créent des faiblesses supplémentaires
elle est râlant là ce que vont faire les
noirs pour se prémunir et vont faire ce
qui se passe dans la partie donc la
famille savent quel chef ne se dépêche
pas y jouer un coup
un peu surprenant puisqu'ils jouent au
10e coup à 4 donc laurent coup qui peut
se comprendre la mesure où peut-être le
fou maintenant fou de cases le fou de
cases noirs des blancs peut aussi on
peut s'estimer qu'on a on aura des
difficultés à pousser ce pion du roi et
donc ce fou peut se développer
maintenant sur la case à 3 ici
contrôleur une diagonale qui a l'air
quand même assez intéressante oui médias
l'ont en fait c'est clair que là on
profite complètement du fait que le fou
donc avons ensuite à quitter son poste
pour éventuellement essayer de se mettre
dans cette diagonale à l'autre idée
positionnelle et que ce option blanc est
tout seul et même sur tout seul c'est
pas bon donc il va essayer de jouer
éventuellement à 5
c'est à dire avancer les pions pour
ensuite l'échanger ce qu'il fera en fait
une peinture faible en moins et oui il y
aura une structure de plus en plus
harmonieuse avec un seul bloc
voilà les faits le pion contact très
important petit rock petit rock donc là
chacun des deux camps milroy l'abri van
der wiel jousse et 5
donc ça c'est un coût qui a pour but de
miner le santon commence à essayer de
d'échanger des pions centre pour pour ne
pas faiblir ce bloc puisque son blog
fort pour les blancs disons que l'idée
de ces 5 n'est pas forcément pendant des
quatre puisque le point des 4 blanc est
quand même fermement tenus par ces
d'options c'est surtout de se prémunir
contre l'avancée blanche aux trois ou
quatre qui maintenant est impossible
puisque le pion des cas très
insuffisamment protégé donc en fait
c'est un peu de la prévention la sf iv
chedjou 12 à 5
donc là il fait exactement ce qu'on a
dit wc d'échangés champions faible sur
quoi van der wiel continue logiquement à
sortir ses pièces avec kelly 17 et
maintenant c'est le moment on joue au 4
mai l'un que le cavalier bouche la dame
le pion des quatre est suffisamment
défendu on peut donc jouer le coup
trouvé qu'un seul fonction des quatre
attaqué deux fois par les pions c5 par
l'option c5f g7
il est défendu par l'option c3 et par le
cavalier froid donc deux attaquants deux
défenseurs ça veut dire que l'option et
ça car ce n'est pas en crise ils
essayent secured prise reprise est là
une petite anicroche tactique
de la part de van der wiel qui déplie
ces pièces avec un assez joli thème
il joue donc cavalier ces cinq sur le
thème du cloud h au 14e coup donc
14e coup sûr votre applet si vous suivez
par ce moyen le cavaly bien en c5 dont
il est en prise par le pion et si ce
pion venait malencontreusement reprendre
le cavalier là on voit que ce fou on g7
se réveille et bien manger mais chamond
la tour 1 donc une tour est plus fort
qu'un cavalier ça on est déjà dit la
tour vos simple quel niveau 3 donc tu en
france et 5 et à éliminer
donc ça a l'air très dangereux puisqu'on
on a l'impression que les noirs peuvent
aussi peuvent du coup essayer de
d'échangés le foot est roi par exemple
ce qui seront peut-être eu sûrement une
bonne opération
attaque aussi lui qui ont eu quatre oui
ça c'est très très important puisque
c'est un tueur centrale et le pion des
quatre aussi maintenant qui attaqué par
la dame et par le fou et le chant des
cas donc c'est un coup aux multiples
menaces qui a l'air très dangereux très
fort mais l'a donc vu à 19 h f bien
entendu a prévu sept cette réplique qui
n'est pas si surprenante que ça et tu
joues au 15e coup j'ai simple donc
commençons à déstabiliser un peu les
pièces les pièces de john d'un kata
quand la dame et posant la question
est-ce qu'on bouge l'adamo ce qu'on
essaie de les prémunir contre ce fou en
fait si on bouge la dame maintenant il
ya un gros problème stéphane c'est que
cavani va être en prison puisque
maintenant que la tour le fou n'est plus
en c1 la dame bien défend la toile est
donc maintenant que j'en pensais 5 / fou
prend tout la dame va reprendre et on a
pris un fou et un cavalier couto et donc
là on est six points contre 5 c'est à
dire faire que les noirs font une
mauvaise opération donc ici très logique
m6 est là moi ça m'a très très surpris
de cette conception il joue 16 des
français 5 tu pense qu'il aurait pu
jouer un autre coup comme un fou en c 2
par exemple
ah non il faut il fallait donc je
reviendrai pas défendu le coup le pian 4
le fou g5 est attaqué en fait non en
fait il n'a pas vraiment d'autre ubc
c'est tout l'ensemble de ces hasards de
la phrase oui qui aboutit en fait à la
perte du fou de cases noires qui je
trouve un peu gênant surprend g5 donc
ici on a échangé en fait le cavalier ses
5 contre le sujet 5la les noirs
maintenant attaque la tour ça c'est un
fait
et ils ont pris la paire de fous ils ont
deux fous alors qu'elle est blonde en
plus que fou et cavaliers mais on était
quelques chefs à trouver des choses à
dire que la pétition sur du long terme
est avantageuse pour les noirs mais il y
a encore des éléments rapides
17e coup tours bien tomber alors ça
c'est un c'est un coût qui finalement il
se retrouve avec une pression énorme sur
la colonne b puisque maintenant il le
pion à le penser et latour d'enfants
pression sur le clan v6 qui ne peut pas
bouger à cause du puy du fou derrière
qui seraient pris par la tour c'est une
sorte de clouage donc grosse pression
sur leur champion est à l'antre éléments
très importants comme dit arrache le
pion à f être bouge toujours trop tôt et
là le roi noir est très faible
c'est à dire quand y'a plus pions f le
roi noir commence à être faible et c'est
surtout ça le
ce que quatre chefs va essayer de mettre
en mettre en valeur tomber un des 5
alors la solution n'est pas en prise en
fait puisque deux possibilités tour
traction ou foot champions d'accord que
l'option des cinq n'est défendue par
rien est attaqué par le fou et par la
tour alors si la tour venez apprendre le
pion donc cette tournée un prendre un
pion le fou 17 viendrait en a six avec
en fait une menace sur le fouet la dame
sûrement me prendrai après le pion à 5
au final donc récupérant le pion oui ici
les échanges ne sont pas bons pour la
dcf chef et si le foot venait prendre ça
laisserait l'option de 400 protection du
fouquet's que je vous planter là qui en
prise par le foot baisse est donc ici on
ne peut pas prendre le pion b5
val-des-cerfs quel chef 18 dames b3w
menaces notamment une qui est très forte
ces options aux six daims prend bien
aussi avec échec avec l'échec qui fait
très mal puisque une fois qu'on a pris
ce pion on se retrouve avec un point de
plus et une très belle position
donc c'est inacceptable et là le pauvre
van der wiel est obligé de jouer un coup
fort déplaisant au 18e qufu s'est vite
donc finalement il oblige les noirs à
revenir donc il a tablé sur cette
conception qui donne la paire de fois
l'adversaire mais qui a cassé un peu
l'harmonie des pions noirs et notamment
ceux qui réussissent maintenant qui
finalement est un pion faible et donc il
va il va essayer de faire pression sur
ce plan et on voit aussi que maintenant
le cube et 5 aussi pour l'instant est
faible
l'option b 5 est en prise le pion aux si
ce n'est n'est pas très bien et les
blancs en un autre atout majeur c'est
l'option c'est donc ici à mon avis la
position reste équilibré peut-être
avantage pour quatre chefs c'est une
position qui n'est pas encore déterminée
beaucoup de choses peuvent se passer au
19e coup ils jouent aux cinq fermant la
diagonale du fou g7 alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils jouent ce coup au 4-5-1
stéphanois alors je pense que salon
effectivement ça confirme le fou et ça
donne aussi peut-être une jolie cazaux
foulard de cases blanches qu'il publie
sur la case eu quatre attaquants la tour
qui post y en a 8 et libérant si la
colonne d
du coup et la deuxième tour pour revenir
sur cette colonne donc c'est un coup
intérêts multiples oui ça reflète bien
ça reflète bien l'idée de ce coût aux
4,5 et ici les noirs jouent dynamique le
19e coup j'ai quatre ça commence à
devenir assez chaud voyez que ce
cavalier f3 est attaqué par le pion que
lecavalier défendez pion aux 5 et donc
par conçu par une analyse assez assez
simple qui embauchent lecavalier on va
perdre le pion au smic et là on commence
une série de coûts intermédiaires
weissach katchalov aux quatre attaques à
tout donc la même topo précédemment si
l'option g4 vient prendre le cavalier f3
noufou prend la tour jeanne et change
favorable aux blancs échange fait
nettement favorable au banc tourbe et
éviter jouer et on continue à harceler
les pièces noires avec tours b d un
attaquant cette dame en des 8
voilà voilà la tournée d'un tacle adams
qui me permettra aux cavaliers de
revenir un jeu au centre exactement donc
dames c'est cet été joués il y avait
éventuellement dame prend 1,5
mais ça changeait pas radicalement le
fond du problème maintenant quels chefs
ne sont qu'à venir des cadres et là vous
voyez que ça on est vraiment
complètement dans le jeu de la dcf
quatre chefs c'est exactement sa
conception c'est les pièces au meilleur
endroit possible
alors là on va aller pointer tout lequel
et des cats ne peut pas être mieux placé
menace éventuellement devenir en c6 nous
faut quatre à une position merveilleuse
aussi bien du côté défensif vers le roi
que pour l'ata qui contrôlent beaucoup
de cazin importante dans le camp blanc
la dame b3 également très bien placé
puisque l attaque le pion aux 6es
l'option b 5 la tour d un superbe sur
cette colonne donc là toutes les pièces
blanches sont au maximum
et puis surtout les pièces blanches sont
placés au centre on peut noter que les
blancs envahissent le centre en fait de
leur leur pièce sont comme on dit en
général on veut dominer centre pour
prendre pour placer ses pièces puisque
le quinqua relie au centre il est mieux
placé que n'importe où ailleurs sauf sur
la case f5 la fameuse case de kasparov
mai mais là il est très très bien perçu
ce cavalier
l'explication du kavé les centrales au
niveau philosophique c'est un cavani se
déplace lentement 1
ça fait 1 2
3 donc ça c'est pas pour aller sur une
zone il faut qu'il soit proche de la
zone physiquement le centre étant dans
des finitions de centres vont essayer
c'est l'idéal pour aller d'une zone à
l'autre il peut aller soit à gauche ou à
droite très vite alors que n'importe où
ailleurs et ça ça serait pas possible
donc là en fait toutes les places de
toutes les pièces toutes les pièces de
vladislav tkachiev sont bien passées a
au contraire dû par exemple pour les
noirs de ce fou civic qui pour l'instant
uniquement un roger uniquement défensif
oui donc en compensation il ya eu la
prise la prise d'un pion donc ici je
pense qu'on va être obligés de
mentionner une variante donc le fo'o 4
est attaqué par la dame aux cinq ici et
vient à l'idée évidemment la fourchette
cavalli ces six attaques la dame et la
tour attaque la dame et la tour donc on
va on va bien protégés et c6 fourchette
est alors sur calais c6 et le fousseret
prix aussi une foule un très petit et
les noirs se retrouver quand même avec
la paire de fou on va montrer la
variante qu'avait laissé six dames 34
quai les premiers huit donc là on est
dans une une ligne virtuelle stéphane
oui c'est bien lille possible qu'ils
enduraient ils ont dû penser évidemment
dans la partie il est en train de voir
les possibilités
et là mon analyse est que dans sept pays
ont donc les blancs ont une qualité plus
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une tour pour un
fou mais il ya un fort coup pour les
noirs qui est donc d'amener cette et
maintenant le cavaly baby tu ne peux pas
être défendue et ne peut pas sortir
toutes les cases étant contrôlé par
l'adam donc ici est le cas les y est
également attaqué par les airs donc le
cac vb 8 va être pris donc globalement
on va prendre une
un cavalier est un fou contre une tour
donc ça deux fous contre une tour pour
les noirs en finale et c'est vraiment
gros avantage c'est un énorme avantage
donc cette variante n'était pas n'était
pas possible pour porter de six à quatre
chefs
il joue donc un coût très très très
amusant dans cette position il un poids
en moins il n'a pas la paire de fou mais
simplement et joue dame
ces deux qui protège le fou est aussi le
pion c5 qui était attaqué ce fameux pion
qui peut s'avérer dangereux puisque
c'est un pion passé donc ces types de
de pousser et de pousser pour la dame et
menace blanche évidemment cavalli c6
fourchette cette fois voilà cette fois
c'est clair les blancs veulent jouer
qu'avait laissé six fourchette donc là
la dame noire bat en retraite
bien sûr la case h5 et là c'est moi je
suis très impressionné par par les
cookies sont jouées actuellement puisque
la au 24e coup donc tranquille il a
besoin de moins son adversaire à la
paire de foulani fait j'arrive pas
produit si ce terrain je vais donc
l'appeler de quatre chefs 4e joue au
24ème coup j'ai trois un coût de
protection d'un coup tranquille coup
tranquille de protection du roi et quels
sont les atouts de la pétition blanche
allait bien on va là on va le voir assez
rapidement van der wiel ne sait plus
trop quoi faire pour ce champion des
champions passe et on peut rappeler ce
que c'est qu'un homme se passait
peut-être oui obtient le passé donc
c'est un pion qui file à dam c'est tout
simplement que j'en qui file à dam
il est protégé par la tourbe et 8 c'est
un petit peu le seul atout des noirs
dans cette position finalement puisque
les biens centraliser toutes leurs
caisses qui sont très actives le roi ben
là on peut dire qu'il est très bien
protégée sur cases noires par les pions
et sur case blanche qu'un souffre ou
qu'il reste une très bonne pièce
défensive est le seul atout des noirs
fait danser ce seront donc van der wiel
le met en valeur pour rester de
contre-attaquer et créer des problèmes
aux blancs 1 peut se poser la question
attention attention espion voyez donc
l'option passé en fait n'être pas
d'opposant pions c'est à dire que là
s'il n'y a pas de pièces sur l'échiquier
le pion fils adam c'est la définition
d'un temps passé et la dame ces quatre
ans donc on continue un peu à taquiner
tu écrivais le pion oui le petit pion là
le type 61.6 mais qu'ils vont la tacc
deux fois maintenant avec la dame c4
avec lequel et des quatre champions et
cloud et en plus c'est aussi le
désavantage d'avoir poussé ce plan on a
donné la caste 4 blanc est cette dame
est peut-être mieux placé que l'attrait
maintenant oui à chaque coup la
desservent augmente la l'énergie
potentielle de ces pièces c'est ça qui
est joli et là il force
john van der wiel a joué fou prend
cavaliers puisque la pression devenait
trop insoutenable le câble et pouvant
aller en c6 ou au cices on décide de
l'éliminer
donc là les blancs déjà récupère
disons fait non plus de désavantages de
la paire de fou il se retrouve quand
même avec un pion de moins mais
ils ont toujours le centre et on peut
vous monte aussi que le plan c'est vais
toujours est passée et a peut-être
peut-être plus dangereux que le plus
anglais des noirs oui en fait je vais
faire une analyse qui est à peu près
similaire à ce que tu viens de dire
c'est que après la reprise évidente au
26e coup d'un gang des 4 on peut faire
un petit bilan sur cette position
du côté gauche de l'échiquier chaque
camp a pu repasser
il ya besoin ici contre un pion là et de
l'autre côté il ya capture pour les
noirs contre trois pour les blancs mais
les pions noirs ne sont pas du tout
compact
c'est à dire qu'ils sont disloqués à
l'image du pion aux six le roi noir est
beaucoup plus faible
indiscutablement que le roi blanc nous
de l'autre côté malgré la supériorité
numérique
c'est le roi blanc qui est mieux
protéger celles et blanc qui ont
davantage en fait sur ce côté là donc
s'il va faire la différence c'est que
des pièces blanches sont mieux
centraliser
ils ont chacun leur temps passé à
pousser et de l'autre côté c'est
équilibré donc le pion aux puces des
noirs en fait jouent un rôle très très
mineur dans cette position donc chacun
ressent qui ont maintenant des trois
pour van der wiel donc là vladislav le
stop tour d2 d'un tour des douaniers que
mon club on sait évidemment plus que
c'est ennuyeux donc là autant le stopper
en b2 ne plairont sait puisque la casse
b2 et contre les deux fois la dame est
et la toya tourne là le four surgit
puisque le pion et si ce n'est plus en
prise avec menace sur la tour eiffel
donc une par une attaque en même temps
un coup là il ya une séquence qui est
assez qui coule de source je dirais oui
najac d'attaqué on l'a on la met en
position de prendre le plan b 3 c ce qui
semble logique
disons que chaque camp joue les coups un
petit peu naturel les voyages les coups
qu'ils ont envie de jouer
là il ya un peu une phase de re de repos
les joueurs sont plus à l'affût de
d'astuces tactique on est en train de
faire un peu le point sur la position
chacun mettant ses pièces au bon endroit
hélas au 29e coup le pion à rillieux la
casse ces six sur la casse c'est si
c'est une très forte aux cases puisque
le fou blanc la contrôler parfaitement
et les sanctionne véritable poison qui
est bien contrôlée au contraire du pur
noire qui menace est il complètement
isolé oui qui à terme va disparaître
mais l'option b 3 est en prise et on a
un petit problème pour attaquer le
l'option ces six puisqu'il faut
l'attaquer avec le fou l'attaqué avec
une des pièces lourdes c'est la dame ou
la tour ne sert plus à rien dans cette
position puisque une puce est une pièce
légère qui le défend donc voilà donc en
fait pour l'attaqué il faudra remettre
en jeu ce fou à 6 ce qui n'est pas même
pas forcément si simple en gardant le
contrôle sur le cube et 3 puisque c'est
aussi un atout important
donc là je pense que les blancs quand
même gagné un peu la bataille la
bataille entre les pions passé qui a eu
lieu 9.5 donc d'options de plus pour
john van der wiel mais c'est une b3 et
virtuellement mort déjà oui alors ici
d'ailleurs il est en prise mais il n'est
pas prix pourquoi et bien sûr donc là
encore on va montrer une variante
virtuel si les blancs prennent le pion
si les blancs prennent l'option b 3 à
mon avis il y à tour f en des beats qui
attaquent la dame qui attaquent la dame
est et ensuite la tournée ensuite la
tour en tout simple tir que si la dame
venait à bouger la tour d2 serait
attaqué deux fois et donc les noix
gagneur une tour simplement l'option b 3
était défendu de manière indirecte par
john van der wiel donc ladislav quatre
chefs là l'attaqué encore une fois il va
un peu il va rendre la colonne des eaux
noires mais il sait que s'il arrive à
prendre l'option des trois options c6 va
devenir un atout énorme dans cette
position puisque les noirs n'ont pas
d'équivalents foulée 5
donc faut bien qu'ils attaquent ce
fameux pions maintenant voilà donc là si
on vient d'apprendre le plan b 3 avec
les blancs les noirs vont prendre
l'option c6 ce qui n'est pas acceptable
donc la zdf encore une fois le défunt
indirectement directement puisque si les
noirs maintenant prennent les pions c6
la dame à 5 et perdu tout simplement oui
donc impossible de prendre option celle
ci ce qui est des produits est
impossible également de défendre
l'option b 3 donc ça y est en fait la
bataille
gagner en plus on attaque une pure
russie soit une chose que j'ai oublié de
mentionner aux multiples fonctions le
pion aux 6 d'où l'intérêt de avant
encore une fois d'avoir les pièces
centralisée cette dame en 5 c'est une
dame centralisée et l attaque à la fois
sur la gauche
l attaque aussi le pion aux 6 et l
annexion vers le roi adverse alors que
la dame noire d'ailleurs une action que
du côté de l'ale dames il donc là les
pièces les pièces blanches domine la
situation tout reprochions b3 la
réplique est forcé le fourbe et
s'inquiétant emprise et évince défense
du fou mais maintenant ce pion c6
s'avèrent des proches de la promotion ou
proches de faire dame c'est un vrai
véritable poison qui peut pousser un c7
il peut il peut créer des menaces
également s'avérer décisif il ya un
élément déterminant dans l'opposition
blanche
je pense que la dame a eu 5 donc on a
donné ses fonctions au coude avant qui
est très très bien placé ne peut plus
être attaqué attaqué ne me ni même
menacé d'être échangé il ya plus de
moyens pour les noirs il faut qu'il faut
vraiment que les noirs se réorganise
rapidement puisque cette dame est très
forte le pion c6 est très fort donc tout
et tout est passé sous contrôle blanc en
fait malgré la supériorité matérielle
des noirs donc tour b 2 tout simplement
pour éviter que le fou noir puisse
attaquer cette tour sur case blanche
je pense que c'est plus profond que ça
quand même en fait on jeu tour b2c un
coup défensif effectivement peut-être de
la prophylaxie pour patrie que la tour
ne soit attaquée sur casse blanche
mais c'est surtout le débat a été
recentré au niveau du pion à f2 ah oui
pour contrôler aussi pour défendre ce
pion f2 qui peut brûler mois qu'il était
attaqué par la tour f 8 et qu'il
menaçait d'être attaqué et
éventuellement par cette dame
la dame a cinq qui pourrait revenir en b
6 pour attaquer le camp de dadis à
quatre chefs en fait n'oublie jamais le
principe numéro un indispensable aux
échecs c'est la défense du roi et là ils
jouent un couple prophylactique c'était
au tour 3 b deux coups qui n'a
apparemment anodin fait se révèle très
importants tours sète et jouer ici et au
34e tour d un donc là évidemment on
récupère la colonne des wii et aux
menaces peut-être de jouer ce tour
maintenant sur la cette fameuse septième
rangée très dangereuse tour en dix-sept
protégé par dieu sait si ce qui peut
s'avérer éventuellement très fort tour
17 nec
on cible mais c'est dans l'air et dans
l'air l'idée principale de tour des ens
et se prémunir contre les changes des
dates donc on va voir la suite de la
partie tout recettes avaient une idée
c'était de jouer dams est donc
maintenant la dame vient on sait cette
chasse est ce le deuxième élément très
fort de la position blanche c'est la
dame aux 5
maintenant que la dame elle a été
défendue par cette tour est ici
vladislav tkachiev s'est prémuni de cet
échange et joue 35e tour des six donc
une sorte d'interception et qui protège
aussi le pion c6 qui empêche l'échangé
dame qui fait pression sur le pion aux 6
en fait ils pénètrent dans le cas
inverse tout simplement ils menacent
probablement de mettre la deuxième tour
sur la case des deux est de faire une
invasion en 17 en dix-sept d'allemands
qui seraient des vins de ce serait
décisive enfin pas tout de suite mais
disons que c'est ça c'est une pression
très difficile à contrecarrer pour les
noirs disons que là la position et
commence à être très très dur à gérer
côté noir
vraiment il a pris toutes les cases
toutes les castes centrale il en a gardé
le contrôle
on l'avait dit au début c'est très
dangereux d'affaiblir les cases noires
et là qu'est ce qui se passe
eh bien les noirs n'ont plus rien sur
cases noires et les pièces blanches qui
sont incrustés oui c'est aussi pourquoi
cette dame est très forte elle ne peut
pas être délogés puisque les cases
noires sont plus du tout défendu on peut
pas jouer le coup fc tf6 non plus avec
les pions il n'existe plus fameux pions
d'où le ce qu'ont expliqué au début
c'est effectivement la faiblesse de ses
cases noires ici très bien démontré par
un par les blancs oui pas remplacement
de pièces astronomiques
ça c'est un aveu d'impuissance et loi
parce que quand un joueur comme ça
revient sur une case l'on peut imaginer
que
vladislav puisse remettre sa tour sur la
case des uns et les noirs se rejouer le
coup dans ses sets
donc c'est c'est quand même un aveu de
faiblesse quand on revient comme ça sur
une position quand on perd mais
l'adversaire ils ont répété les coups
c'est qu'on n'espère pas plus que faire
partie d'une c'est vrai mais d'un autre
côté ça peut être un élément aussi
psychologique
c'est à dire qu'on peut inciter notre
adversaire à croire qu'on est d'accord
pour faire nul et au coup suivant
changer de changer trou faire c'est peut
être une sorte d' intox qui a été
utilisée par les russes pendant très
longtemps je sais que kasparov dis
toujours je répète la pression d'abord
et je réfléchis après oui voilà qui
résume bien la situation
tours b en d2 donc vous êtes rassasiés
les deux tours sans sont postés
idéalement sur la colonne des la colonne
ouverte
la menace est probablement de jouer tour
en 17 qui a l'air d'être un coup très
très fort très fort autour des 7 est au
programme donc évidemment on l'a déjà
dit beaucoup de fois dans diagonale la
septième rangée est très importante
cirque on s'attaque directement aux rois
on peut imaginer tour des sept îles et
noir reprennent on prendrait de la tour
et la menace d'armes g7 matt gagnerait
très vite la partie
alors petit inconvénient de taille
variant de stephen après tour 17
matt maintenant de quoi il y aurait des
maths
comme mentionné c'est que si cette dame
on a 5 vient sur les 15e avec regret oui
le roi devra monter en g2 et là on
plantera le mat dame de josé oui la
rubrique de la dernière fois un adapteur
est ce un échec et mat
oui tout à fait voilà donc il faut faire
attention au sida n'est pas d'actualité
les deux rois son ennui dans le vent et
c'est là que s'élèvent tourner le débat
damas trois de john van der wiel et
vladislav tkachiev trouve encore entre
joly après damas trois on sent que son
roi est un peu dans le réseau se plonger
4 est une vraie plaie
pour les blancs puisqu'il option angers
carte contrôler les cases f3 et h3 donc
ce n'est le roi de long dans une sorte
de boîte et l' ouverture de la boîte
avec h4 qui crée une case qui traînent
casse pour le roi donc là il va dire une
prise en passant oui donc pour le pl est
amis c'est vrai qu'elle appelait tana
fonctionne pas sur la prise en passant
dans la fameuse prise en passant donc là
le pion blanc viennent jouer un coup d
un coût normal qu'ils aient h 2 h 4 et
le coup d'après les noirs en droit de
considérer que ce plan est en cours sur
la case h3 ça s'appelle la prison
passera donc on prend le pion h4 tout
simplement sur la case h3 voilà et le
pion disparaît pas sur la planète parce
que la pl est un petit problème quand on
règlera bientôt bientôt ses pions le g
france 3 est la plaie dcf quatre chefs
continue et il joue au 38ème courage de
prophylaxie prophylaxie en fait masser
avril éviter les échecs et le roi et
plus sécure comment ni un sur cette case
age 2 est bon le sou blanc contrôler les
cases blanches à côté la seule classe
faible prix du roi c'est la casse j'ai
finalement mais on voit mal comment les
noirs pourraient venir sur cette case
pour y venir enlever tout à fait donc 38
3 h de leroy blanc parfaitement protégé
l'option c6 toujours en état d'avancées
oui la menace peut être aussi devant la
dame c'est un même si un coup aux
multiples fonctions on va on va compter
puisque ça revient la défense de ce pion
là éventuellement ça veut passer en f1
pour attaquer le pion m2 donc il ya un
coût en fait van der wiel remet saddam
ont joué ils essaient de leur cv le roi
blanc qui s'adresse à ceux son seul
espoir finalement puisque sur toute la
positionnement sur les autres secteurs
de jeu il est complètement dominés sur
la position
oui c'est à dire que ces pièces sont
toutes
elles sont derrière les pions elles sont
mal placés ces pièces sont pas
dangereuses et le dernier élément que
les noirs pour avoir c'est le pion à 6
mais on est quand même très très loin de
d'une menace donc la réaliser avec
hachey profite encore une fois de la
force de la centralisation des pièces ce
qui va mettre sa case simplement sur une
autre case centrale ils triplent sur la
colonne des tripes et sur les colonies
est encore un coup aux multiples
fonctions puisque ça défend la viande de
lehfen option f2 qui est un des enjeux
l'unique l'unique option pour le contre
jeune noir donc dès maintenant on peut
imaginer des coups aussi contours des
huit la tour pourrait venir
éventuellement sur la classe des huit
toujours éventuellement sur la case 17
faut voir en famille de la toux rendez
vite ici on va le pointe et voilà tous
rendez pourrait venir entre des vite
avec des menaces des chèques et
d'invasion du pain noir
oui dames 1
pour ces deux là c'est qu'on continue à
construire alors toutes les pièces
blanches se défendent en train de
mutuelles mans on voit que le fouet 4
est défendu par l'ademe des quatre te
fais un petit schéma logique s'appelle
centralisation moi j'aime beaucoup de
temps dès parle bien le fou défend les
tours j'aime beaucoup dans cette partie
là aussi la centralisation des pièces de
blanc on voit vraiment la force du
centre dans cette partie les pièces
centrales malgré le pion de tout à
l'heure il y avait le pion de plus il a
fini par par tomber et vladislas n'a pas
arrêté de jouer sur le centre avait des
pièces au centre on voit la force que ça
dégage
voyez en fait il faut un élément ou plus
c'est à dire qu'il ya toutes ces pièces
au centre qui sont très fortes mais
sanctions c6 ça n'aurait pas de sens à
100 les besoins des faits ce sera un
sens plutôt défensif là c'est vraiment
offensif ouais donc là le tour ces deux
sa menace venait de jouer c'est cet
essai 8 dames
oui le kilo fans option passé voilà qui
n'est plus d'opposants et qui demandent
qu'à avancer donc jusqu'à la promotion
et là je crois que c'est la gaffe n ont
pas encore vingt quand tu es est donc qu
il continue il joue son va tout sur ce
pion f2 voici comment s'attaquer après
attaqué trois fois par les deux tours et
par la dame qui a taclé alors qu'il n'a
défendu que deux fois donc là un petit
coup tranquille elle de la droite tout
simplement ça empêche
les tours dax de d'avoir accès à la kz2
et ses protégés par le fou donc ici plus
de problèmes fu eux deux ont continué
d'attaquer mais là problème justement
parce que c'est la dame l'avait
empoisonné l'existence des noirs et là
problème vient se placer sur la case aux
3 ici tout simplement clouage attaque
double attaque du fou et 2 et si la
foudre nous sommes évidemment si le foot
bouge en prenant par exemple piot f3 et
bien la dame noire est perdu donc en
fait les noirs perdre leurs sous
finalement en essayant de jouer leur
va-tout quitter finalement d'essayer
d'attaquer ce roi noir sera blanc pardon
mais ils étaient obligés parce que la
menace des blancs c'est cet essai vite
et est maintenant imparable fallait
essayer de trouver quelque chose et
finalement ils perdent une pièce est
donc faux dos et en fait c'est un peu
pour le public
je pense que au lieu d'abandonner dans
une position qui semble obscur
éventuellement il mais il joue faut deux
pour éclaircir un peu pourquoi il
pourquoi il a perdu
sachant bien que de toute façon sa
position ne ferait aucun espoir 1 qu
auparavant par a donc finalement le guen
pièces et puis toujours ce pion c6 qui
va aller à grands traits blancs conserve
en plus tout leur être footballeur à
tour ici une application continuer la
partie donc abandon des noirs qui n'ont
plus qu'ils n'ont plus de jeux qui m'ont
plus simplement de plans possibles à
leur disposition donc très jolie partie
sur le thème du centre et du puy ont
passé le centre le temps passé et
surtout la connexion entre les pièces un
peu tout c'est interactivité de pièces
blaise f4 chef est un vrai spécialiste
un véritable artiste dans ce domaine ces
sacs en théorie si vous avez l'occasion
de le voir ou de lui en parler il est
très prolixe dit oui pour l'aider à ce
sujet il aime beaucoup parler de sa
conception des échecs
et là c'est une belle démonstration
supplémentaire voilà donc très jolie
partie de faire ça vous a plu en tout
cas et on va passer à l'intérieur des
métas ça va devenir une habitude et le
vois je crois parce qu'on a nous avons
une rubrique un petit petit josé un
petit josé donc on va voir la rubrique
dodgers et voilà la rubrique de josé
maintenant
oui
je
voilà donc la rubrique de josé bonsoir
jose alors qu'on s'a en soft et fanon
soir chez l'internaute donc soirée loi
bon sang qu'est-ce que tu dois préparer
pour ce soir alors bien fait avec un peu
la continuité d'une huitaine dernière
fois sur la prise des décisions
parce que bien sûr en une séance on n'a
pas le temps de tout voir en une petite
rubrique mêmes c'est un sujet très vaste
donc quelques où jouait dans
l'opposition c'est un sujet très vaste
alors on avait vu quand même disons
notre but c'est pas de se donner un peu
de méthode un peu pour un pour répondre
à cette question quel coup joué dans une
position bien donné alors on avait dit
et je pense que d'accord avec moi qu'il
ne faut pas jouer le premier coup qui
passe par l'esprit sans analyser puisque
bon une fois on peut avoir de la chance
mais pas plus ensuite on avait dit qu'on
avait une autre une autre recommandation
si ce n'est de ne pas analyser le
premier coup qui venait à l'esprit parce
que bon il ya peut-être des coûts plus
intéressant à analyser d'abord et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on avait fait une liste
de coups candidats arrivés dès
nécessaire de faire une liste des
candidats on avait aussi précisé qu'on
n'était pas là nous ne sommes pas des
ordinateurs comme disent les gens de la
science cognitive nous avons une
rationalité limitée
c'est à dire on ne peut pas traiter
toute l'information on ne peut pas
toutes analysées donc il faut se
restreindre et faire une liste
restreinte de deux coups et pour ça on
sait déposer une question alors j mais
si tu te souviens des questions qui ont
été posées d'abord dans la fois c'était
quelle est la menace qu'elle amène ainsi
à la menace permet de restreindre ses
coûts c'est la première question sur
laquelle j'aimerais revenir pour que ce
soit bien clair il faut parer la menace
si un adversaire menace maths il est
nécessaire de paris cette menace avant
tout d'accord donc c'est pour ça qu'on
va prendre une petite bille position si
vous voulez bien avec
avec ce problème voilà donc si on peut
aussi on peut mettre un terrain sur la
vidéo la position de josé aujourd'hui
voilà donc c'est une position qui tirait
de la pratique je crois jose alors m'a
toujours fait du siècle toujours ce soit
un peu un peu réel et donc c'est une
partie assez ancienne de 1954 quelques
jours à berlin entre deux amateurs
regard loin serre on regarde un peu ce
qu au début j'étais coiffe une partie
des lois elles sont ciblées plus ils
avaient raison chez valve utile de jouer
une partie d'amateurs
alors dans cette position on voit on
voit bien que la case alors devant le
roi est un peu faible alors attends
voyelles parce que je crois que la
position est pas encore à la position
des banques autant que voilà ça y est
donc on voit la position voilà donc la
caisse devant le roi qui m'ont les
caisses g7 est un peu faible devant le
roi devant le roi noir parce qu'il y a
une batterie c'est ce qu'on appelle à
une batterie avec le fouet la dame qui
contrôle qui contrôle cette case g7 et
qui menacent le roi donc le roi est en
grand danger
d'autre part on voit aussi que la tour
en d3 sur la troisième rangée est très
bien passé et peuvent venir aussi aider
à attaquer le roi de moi donc la
position semble très menaçante quoi les
blancs menace de prendre d'angers 7 et
de faire mais je pense qu'il faut oui
voilà donc ça on en vient en fait que
c'est au noir de jouer bien sûr fait
super bravo bonne au blanc de jouer le
milieu aurait d'approcher cette manne
sera la prochaine est donc la menace est
très forte
donc bien sûr on ne bat jouer un coup
alors est-ce qu'il faut montrer un coût
qui serait complètement à l'opposé de
l'échiquier
bon c'est je crois que c'est clair pour
tout le monde à coup comme à 5 perdrait
dessus puisqu'il ne me projette donc ça
va limiter les coûts possibles alors les
coûts le premier coup c'est de prendre
la dame
bien sûr ça c'est le coup le coup qu'on
regarde oui parce que là il ya plus de
si on prend la tête oui quitte avoir
fait erreur technique
donc si on comprend la dame avec le pion
tout simplement donc josé surprend le
plus on évite d'en prendre sept matches
voilà on essaie de la province à l'autre
coup ici qui me paraît un malt rapide
c'est un échec par exemple souvent bon
donc peut-être que le mieux c'est de ma
position est une très haut noir d'accord
donc je vais repart mettrai donc très
vite sans fin vite fait reparamétrer la
police militaire royale ce que la voie
la rue sinon c'était donc valable de
montrer donc la menace très large et
j'ai 36 ou alors je prends ici dès le
premier coup qu'on analyse est le 2ème
maintenant c'est un échec ces dames 20
et d'amener un échec
je pense que avant de passer à damon en
échec il faut peut-être expliquer
pourquoi option prend 1,6 ne marche pas
là non justement dans la baie d'accord
les cochers voilà justement lazer loi
fait l'ajustement la faute ne pas
analyser au premier coup un coût mais
plutôt de faire une liste des candidats
d'accord est ensuite analysé coup par
coup beaucoup de bien faire une méthode
bien strictes conditions prend ici c'est
demain il ya un autre coup aussi qui
parle maths qui est intéressant c'est
dame g4 la dame est en prise mais le
maté paris donc bon on va on va revenir
analyse est alors le couac d'alzheimer
il ya dire d'autre coup jose iliad a
mené fin d'un retrait de bndes et un
d'impro f2 est aussi d'amener un chèque
voilà dame neige mais bon j'ai
sélectionné finalement trois coups
possibles je pense que c'est une bonne
moyenne trois coups puis si vraiment
dans ces trois coups il n'y a pas la
solution on va chercher un peu ailleurs
mais comme j'ai deviendra une
rationalité limitée donc on peut pas
analyser tous les coups possibles donc
il faut restreindre une liste à trois
coups et on l'a restera en fonction de
l'art et de la question quelle est la
menace donc on va d'abord regarder g
prend ainsi ce qui paraît le couple
normal tu l'as tu l'a souligné on prend
la dame
celui-ci jamais et c'est bon en général
on est content
apple déconne alors donc maintenant bien
sûr là les blancs peuvent jouer tour
j'ai trois échecs
donc la tour peut venir en g3 avec le
chèque au roi j'ai comme moi après tu
peux montrer la tour l'action de la tour
lois sont de la tour remarquablement
donc maintenant bon ce n'est pas le seul
coup mais il ya un coût d'interposition
be seen on voit ensuite sa part est plus
normal et maintenant le fou qui se
réveille et qui vient administrer un
match voilà donc un terme at on donne la
dame finalement le on donne la dame ont
maté pour mater alors on avait bien vu
au début
l'action du fou et de l'adam conjointe
sur la grande diagonale est très fort
donc il faut bien sûr trouver notre coup
paraît alors maintenant on va analyser
notre deuxième coup candidat qui est
d'un bleu en échec alors maintenant bien
sûr tu me tout remarqué la dame étant
prises donc les blancs pour eh oui pour
andreu la dame on pourrait sauter sur
l'occasion et c'est l'adhésion prom
également l'homme mais à ce moment là
les noires récupérées
la dame est la position de noir et
maintenant il sauve puisque le fou a
quitté la grande diagonale
donc j'aurai plus le mat avec le matin
f6 donc plus le même
donc finalement c'est un sacrifice de
déviation des mains quand cette
déviation du fou donc maintenant on est
sur les rois le roi les les blancs
peuvent mettre à l'abri le roi donc
fouillé croire h2 en évitant de prendre
la dame pour garder les menaces de maths
finalement là pour garder la mairesse de
magma temps la position les mêmes que
tout à l'heure et il faut trouver un
couple et noir il est maintenant le seul
coût possible c'est de donner la dame
contre le fou pour éviter du mat dans la
dame reprend sa compagne quoi financer
son jeune adversaire
hélas les blancs sont mieux mais les
bleus ont probablement une position
gagnante oignons puis soulignant que
techniquement peu difficile mais
gagnante
donc ces deux premiers candidats n'ont
pas à porter leurs fruits
finalement si on s'était limité au
départ assez de coups possibles bon ben
il aurait fallu rechercher d'autres
comme on a vu un troisième
on va regarder ce troisième coup
possible qui est d'alger qu'alors qu'il
paraît surprenant alors c'est bon et
surprenant
déjà il faut voir que sa part j'espère
qu'avec une flèche verte tu peux nous
montrer le rouge tu peux vous montrer
que ça contrôlent la quasi fait et ça
aussi notre vertu sa menace
matt angers 2-1 contre une contre mana
donc souvent les cookies sont comme ça
deux contres menaces on sent très fort
en ce sens très fort voilà l'occasion de
conjuguer aussi du fou et de l'adam
menace mais bon bien sûr le coup ici
paraît aberrant mgk puisque les blancs
pourraient prendre la dame simplement pu
engranger 4 mais là il est plus précis
possible transformation c'est que
maintenant la colonne g est bouché pour
le tour on remarque que les maintenant
des mois peuvent prendre les dames n'ont
maintenant tour g3 tu veux montrer que
tout rejet 3 ne fait plus j'avais placé
le chef puisque le pion jason g4 que tu
peux indiquées en rouge
d'où la beauté de ce coup d'objets
cadeaux surprenants surprenant et
surprenant finalement si on n'avait pas
mis sur les coulisses des candidats mais
est ce vraiment la solution parce qu'ils
aient d'autres coups possibles tout à
l'heure stéphane mentionnait un coup une
autre coup que la prise aux dames donc h
plongée 4 donc ici d'un g4 voilà
maintenant un autre coup qui est tour g3
finalement donc maintenant tu veux
montrer que les blancs finalement par
interposition attaque toujours par
rayons x
le roi est là et on peut toujours pas
prendre la dame blanche puisque on se
retrouverait après tout reprendre dames
on va dans le même match
que tout à l'heure donc maintenant ben
il ne reste plus aux noirs de sacrifier
lors d'un contre les tours toujours par
toujours le match angers 7 et menace
toujours en g2 est donc la bombe et les
blancs reprennent d'un et les noirs
prennent des dames et ils sont retrouvés
du trou de plus ils ont miné la partie
donc très jolie défense a pas de
sacrifice de là mais il faut voir aussi
qu'on peut après prendre la tour donc ce
fait ces deux coups subtilement mais de
cause utile mais quand on a trouvé le
premier après l'enchaînement semble
logique on sacrifie une fois la dame
pour qu'on ne peut laisser qui fait deux
fois en plus des prises de la tour donc
voilà donc en plus et demi une pièce
d'attac
donc conclusion la conclusion c'est la
nécessité de faire une liste de
candidats qui le monde ne se limite pas
un coup on a dit faut pas jouer le
premier groupe qui nous passe par
l'esprit ne pas analyser le premier coup
qui nous passe par l'esprit mais faire
une liste de candidats du candidat en
harmonie avec la position
voilà donc liste un peu en ligne alors
pour moi cet exemple à un autre si un
autre effet intéressant c'est ça peut
être là la façon de trouver un coût par
une méthode d'exception voilà exact
c'est à dire que les premiers coups
envisagé perdent on a vu un shampoing
9,6 on se fait mater très vite
damian échec on perd aussi la partie
donc ça nous encourage à chercher encore
une nouvelle possibilité un peu
aberrante je n'y ai donc finalement le
dame g4 le coup surprenant donc ça peut
être un exemple que vu des de manière
aussi bien la méthode qu'on appelle
d'exception en russie que la méthode des
coûts candidats mentionnés prix
en tout cas cette recherche de coûts
candidat me permet de trouver des coûts
exceptionnels du vote revoilà très très
jolie démonstration josé donc merci
merci totalité à la semaine prochaine
dans les prochaines années seront sur le
même thème avec un peu plus aujourd'hui
en pleine forme ces soirées
ce qu'on peut dire alors c'est que la
semaine prochaine en reste là d'avoir
alors je dis en risque parce qu'on va
essayer une interview exceptionnelle
puisqu'il s'agit du champion du monde
l'instrument des chèques dont alexander
kalichman web que nous allons
probablement rencontrer demain à
l'anniversaire de la deûle à ces
derniers n'y fit des oueds de la vieille
qui a 75 75 avant tout à fait la vieille
dame un peu comme juventus quoi comment
nier donc oui l anniversaire de la
fédération internationale qui a eu à
paris donc place de la concorde
demain samedi avec éloi pas mal de beau
monde puisqu'on va retrouver tienne
macro je crois la championne du monde
l'achèvement du monde féminine kyun faut
rappeler on n'a pas beaucoup parlé dit
paul car elle n'est pas championne mende
parce qu'elle joue pas le championnat du
monde féminin oui disons que ça et on
peut faire un parallèle entre judit
polgar et garry kasparov
aucun des deux ne sont champions du
monde mais ce sont tous les deux les
meilleurs joueurs chose du monde
tout à fait et elle considère aussi que
elle préfère lutter pour le championnat
du monde toutes catégories qu'elle
estime c'est le seul titre en tout cas
le seul titre qui l'intéressent qu'il
est clairement dans les échecs féminin
en train de dominer assez nettement la
situation
donc on verra donc si oui qui est quand
même une très forte joueuse chinoise et
puis qui on a parlé aussi de la chine au
réveil de la chine c'est une des
démonstrations et des confirmations de
ce réveil et puis donc du beau monde
quoi donc il y aura aussi ponomariov le
petit craignent un qui a battu le record
détiennent bacrot en précocité grand
maître a 14 ans et un mois de moins je
crois quelque chose comme ça oui ça
s'est joué à quelques semaines près
quelques semaines le titre
le record du meilleur aux plus jeunes
grands maîtres du monde qui a été battu
depuis deux ans encore je crois non
alors qu'il n'a pas été battu mais par
contre un espoir donc chinois oui qui a
13 ans qui a fait 3 nombre de grands
maîtres dont il n'a pas été validé
puisque le tournoi était sur une durée
trop courte enfin pour une obscure
raison de règlements le jeune chinois de
13 ans ne sera pas grand maître au
prochain congrès de la fidh et mais de
toute façon on est très forts de plus en
plus jeunes c'est une
une remarque qu'on est obligé de se
faire quand on voit les âges record
voilà donc demain donc des lieux ces 8
place de la concorde
si l'automobile club de france 75e
anniversaire de la fidh et avec le
président et des grands naître et je
crois qu'une petite manifestation
sympathique et on va essayer de rester
de rencontrer kalichman et puis on verra
donc je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
vous verrez le résultat voilà donc la
semaine prochaine merci d'avoir suivi
des gones al ce soir